Nielsen is the Secretary of Homeland
Security and she joins us now the
secretary thanks very much for for
coming on my pleasure so what is the
executive branch doing now to fix this
well if I don't have enough time for me
to tell you all the things I mean look
just as you said at the top of your
introduction the president predicted
this as a candidate he predicted this
before he was a candidate he continues
to show leadership and to raise the
alarm bells but only now are we starting
to see a mainstream press not on this
particular channel that there is a
crisis and that's what there is so what
we're doing is we have announced that we
are sending more migrants back to Mexico
to await their immigration proceedings
we are pulling folks from the ports of
entry to help interdict those who are
choosing to come here illegally it is a
crime and despite what you just showed
sitting senators saying it is a crime to
coming legally between ports of entry to
stop them and to provide humanitarian
assistance by the smugglers they're
coming through remote areas they're
sicker than we've ever seen before
yes so will we see an executive order
from the White House to make verify
nationwide to punish employers who are
setting the bait in this trap we're
encouraging illegal aliens to come into
this country that is part of the problem
I mean I think what you saw also in the
clip that you showed is many of the
people coming are economic migrants they
are not truly seeking a sign we want to
help those who are but many of them have
been given magic words to come in and to
get a job and take that job away from an
American so we are looking to increase
rates that you verify we've made it
easier for employers to comply with it
but we're looking to do everything we
can throughout the system to apply
penalties where we why wouldn't your
agency write an executive order
presented to the president have them
sign it and do it tomorrow everything is
on the table we'll do everything we can
within our authorities what's the
argument against doing that ah there's
just a debate with Congress as to
whether the executive branch has the
authority to do that we can expand the
program but right now it's only
authorized in a voluntary way not a
mandatory way so we can do it but as you
know what happens when we do is we get
in joined by the
so it's one of many issues we're looking
to work with Congress on will continue
to drive that do you think I mean it
looks from I mean you probably have
fresher knowledge than we do out here
but it looks like Congress is not going
to act because one party has a vested
interest in changing the population and
the other party is in effect controlled
by people who want illegal immigration
so would there be a downside for the
President to act unilaterally on that
question or for example birthright
citizenship would you be willing to
draft an executive order eliminating
birthright sentences I think you know
Chuck I think the president's been clear
all of that is on the table
including to close down the border we
have to stop this flow into our
communities we have to stop the drugs we
have to stop the smuggling and
trafficking of gangs he's very serious
about it sir yes I think everything is
on the table in the meantime I remain
optimistic in the sense that I refuse to
believe that the United States Congress
will not act I just it's not a person is
it no it's not and I of course I agree
and we've spent you know countless hours
on making that exact point but here you
have the president who ran on the
promise it really was this the central
promise of his campaign to secure the
border and things seem less under
control now
than they did then and so when you ask
about it the answer is well Congress
won't act when everyone knows they're
never going to act and so it does seem a
little like buck-passing if you see yeah
I do I would say I would expand that
group a little bit you mentioned the
courts yeah we have a lot of in my
opinion court decisions that do not
understand the full situation the
operational realities that we face every
day and it's also the criminals and I
think you saw that in the clip to the
smugglers are more active than ever
before it advertising how to come into
this country with a child we've broken
up so called child recycling rings if
you can believe it in the last couple
months which is where smugglers kidnap a
child they give it to an adult to cross
the border present themselves as a
family once they get in because as you
know we can only hold families for
twenty days they send the child back and
bring the child back with another family
another fake famil
don't sew the criminals play a huge part
of this we're working to crack down on
all the transnational criminals the
gangs and smuggling and trafficking but
I cannot be clear and I don't think the
president can be any clearer he will
take every action within his authority
to stop this flow yeah
so do we does the US government know
exactly how many people were living in
this country illegally I've seen
academic studies that put that number
between 11 million 22 million maybe more
what is the real number we debated I
think that's accurate
we don't mention it we do not know know
and part of that think about it part of
it is because we do not have the wall
that the president continues to advocate
for we cannot in every circumstance tell
you who is crossing the border law
enforcement agency many roles but
exactly in the country that's right
probably the world actually yeah
probably so that must be a grave concern
to you that we potentially have more
than 10 million people here whose
identities we don't know could be over
20 whose identities we don't know and
like they could be anybody
yes and so why is that not the single
most pressing problem the country has in
my opinion right now this is one of if
not the biggest crisis this country has
faced in a decade truly I mean security
aspects of this humanitarian aspects of
this have got to be address so I agree
with you I would this is at the very top
of our list at DHS we've announced today
that we're now treating this like a
massive cat5 hurricane disaster we are
bringing all of the interagency together
we're asking everybody to chip in we
need to sword surge down as many
resources we can to the border but
Congress needs to you look at this as a
hurricane to right where is the
supplemental where the additional
Authority I mean I've covered hurricanes
and natural disasters and and you see
men in a uniform with rifles you see the
National Guard there yeah I read a bunch
of background quotes from hi from flag
officers in the United States military
who said that's a frivolous Duty for us
we've got a real duty is over in Syria
or whatever some other country
why wouldn't we put the US military
along our border if it's really a crisis
of that magnitude I think we're looking
into that we
made the request I'm in constant contact
with the Acting Secretary of Defense I
talked to some of the combatant
commanders today we are in fact pushing
more and more military resources to the
border and that's what I tried I mean
the president is the commander in chief
of the facility would it be possible for
him to say we're moving troops to the
border tomorrow and this is I mean he
could say we're moving troops to
Venezuela tomorrow if he wanted but he
can't do it to our own border no I think
he absolutely of course has full
authority to defend our country right
and I think that's what he's moving to
do I mean his statements in the last
week about closing the border a perfect
example he will take all action that is
required to do this so yes it's on the
table we're actively moving in
discussions about moving more troops
down now we're working with the National
Guard's working with the States but
absolutely DoD plays a huge part of this
so just one last question and I don't
even know if you have an answer but why
is it that the press many in Congress
don't seem to recognize the magnitude of
this do you think it's that they don't
know the details or they don't care do
you have you want to speculate as to why
no one's look at this point I'll be
blunt
I think they're blinded by politics
unfortunately they are blinded for what
they see as a request from this
administration instead of looking at the
requests and the way it's which it is
directly affecting Americans I mean you
mentioned fentanyl last year alone CBP
and ice interdicted more fentanyl to
kill every American four times I mean
the the effects that are this is having
an American society cannot be understood
how much got through without being we do
not but the good news is the president
requested and did receive additional
resources at the border to interdict
drugs and we are actively implementing
this but to your point the facts don't
lie so I don't believe that they don't
see it or they don't understand it they
are just willfully choosing to ignore it
but the more Americans who suffer
they're going to have to look at this I
hope they do it sooner than later I hope
so too
thank you very much my pleasure thank
you